mein thema heute aber ist dass ich finde
chemikalien gesetze und agenturen die
schädigungen und ich würde sagen es hat
gleichen tag sozusagen vegan die antwort
tierversuche müssen umgehend gestoppt
mehr mit lobbyismus zu tun als mit der
kommen einfach nicht runter von ihrem
hohen ross und dabei sind sich quasi
verwerflichkeit der leute ja also ja
ist auf massentierhaltung oder ob die
werden alleine in europa leiden jedes
anfang ist weniger jain und früher
gerade zwei gesetzte denn wir haben ja
müsste man noch mal austarieren aber es
jahr neun millionen tiere sie leiden
dieses gesetz von 2013 und wir haben die
einfach mal dass er am tag sei da war
kann sogar sein dass dieses gesetz noch
nicht nur sie werden zu tode gequält im
klar es gibt ein ei zu sonntag und nicht
mal gibt peter sucht gerade über eine
rahmen von tierversuchen jetzt mag der
chemikalien vereinigung und die beißen
irgendwie morgens am netz und keine
millionen unterschriften
ahnung was
ansonsten könnte es sein dass
eine oder andere denken käufersuche sind
sich aber das tieres wohl wird einfach
doch illegalen das dachte ich auch 2013
deutschland dieses gesetz eben nochmal
nach wie vor ist kleiner angesehen und
wir glaube ich alle einig dass diese
entschärft und tierversuche nochmal viel
trat dieses gesetz in kraft es wird
das wird einfach totgeschwiegen ich als
tierquälerei nicht geht ja aber ich
endverbraucher städte verstehe
einfacher durchgeführt werden können
allerdings zunichte gemacht klein
vorprodukten weiß überhaupt nicht ich
also jeder der sich jetzt zum beispiel
würde mir gerne mal sagen dass gute
heimlich still und leise von der
war schockiert bei meiner recherche wie
etwas engagieren möchte etwas und direkt
kommt sozusagen im gesamten im
europäischen chemikalienagentur die
viele kosmetik giganten nach wie vor
lobbyismus der politik praktisch nicht
wie ganze werden könnte zumindest diese
weiterhin fordert dass gewisse substanz
tiere töten bewusst töten 4 millionen
vor wir könnten eine autofahrt
petition unterschreiben die peter
nur benutzt werden dürfen wenn sie an
regenwälder oder die landwirtschaft
aktuelles leben gerufen aber ist august
tieren getestet werden und ich finde das
tiere werden in deutschland jedes jahr
reden wir können über keine ahnung was
ich möchte einen ganz praktischen werner
direkt nach der tat nach deren geburt
impfstoffe zum beispiel reden ja wann
ist ein absolutes unding ich habe sogar
schlager chen möchte einen ganz
die unterlaufen einigen tests die sozis
praktischen vorschlag machen zu ihr zu
eine eigene kleine firma gegründet ich
immer wir können über alles mögliche
erfüllen sie nicht uns 4 millionen tiere
wurde zeuge davon dass produkte
ihrem thema er muss sei noch eine minute
reden aber wenn es dafür darum geht so
werden sofort in die mülltonne gekippt
frau rieke veröffentlichen wir doch
günstiger hergestellt werden wenn sie an
das problem ist also strukturell dass
das ist mein ernst 3 mio eur 117
tieren getestet werden und das finde ich
diese firmen diese kosmetikfirmen die
man sozusagen am guten und am weniger
millionen tiere werden jedes jahr
muss im jahr 22 einfach aufhören tiere
lieferketten gesetz auch gutes beispiel
geschlachtet 770 millionen tiere
auf die immer noch tierversuche
wir können auch alle mal irgendwie ein t
sind genauso viel wert wie menschen und
erfüllen quasi diese kriterien an denen
durchführen ich könnte in einen direkter
shirt statt 5 t shirts kaufen dann wäre
das kann so nicht weitergehen
kann man dann munter und fröhlich los
regen nennen es war jemand gekommen dass
kann man in die kosmetik lobby in die
testen und 4 millionen tiere werden
das lieferketten gesetzt vielleicht auch
sofort umgebracht anstatt zumindest
schranken weise erst einmal kann ich
man mal die namen und ich finde die idee
noch hätte nochmal eine andere dimension
insofern bin ich das völlig dabei aber
ihnen dann nur zustimmen alleine ich
einen plan b in erwägung zu ziehen für
gut dass auf jeder kosmetik packung
die eigentliche frage ist wie kann man
finde es unglaublich dass man in das man
diese tiere die schon mal nicht für die
den lobbyismus durchbrechen meine
stehen muss für dieses produkt wurden
tests in summe immerhin werden die
männlichen küken nicht wieder so
antwort oder mein vorschlag wäre
immer noch tiere quält ja und wenn man
tierversuche durchgeführt von anfang an
fortgeschritten aber du siehst du das
packaging als wenn man auf jedem was
jemals gesehen hat wie so ein hund
sagst aber ich würde gerne eine sache
kann dann kann der verbraucher die
auch immer ein kosmetikprodukt drauf
leidet werden augentropfen zum beispiel
schreiben würde für dieses dinge sind
eine sache erwähnen und zwar für das
verbraucherin selber entscheiden denn
ich bin gegen diese ganzen verbote kein
bei kosmetik sachen liegen die augen
leid der tiere müssen wir endlich nicht
drei über den musiker retten über
erinnerung etwas oder oder nicht auch
unbedingt nach politikern rufen sondern
führt was diese hunde oder auch
fleisch kein rauchen kein
vorschlagen dass man so etwas machen
wir selber können ja auch dafür tun ja
einfamilienhaus wir uns
bevor wir also alle jetzt vegan leben
panik haben und nicht glaube das ist ein
indem wir nämlich einfach unser
also ich baue auf die eigene
verhalten ändern indem wir andere
dabei müssen sie herr raucher so viel zu
das ist ein problem das die politik
verantwortung den menschen gehabt dass
kosmetik produkte kaufen oder ich finde
lassen sie werden im endeffekt immer
bei den eiern auch schon geschafft
was kapital lieber im sexy ist das weil
lösen muss denn diese versuche diese
noch das günstigste produkt kaufen oder
diese klemmte vegan ist uns existiere
weil sie schon ist das freiland ist das
tierversuche sind ja trotzdem in
was sie gerade wie heißt du hast mir
diese woche lange
irgendeiner form erforderlich um die
bereich uns an der konsolidierung
käfighaltung oder sonst was kommt
199 hackfleisch ja das muss man sich
sondern du kannst ja auch zum beispiel
unbedenklichkeit gewisse kosmetik
kein fleisch essen ja also wir einmal
aber
produkte zu garantieren die eigentlich
trotzdem also was manche menschen können
sich wirklich mit dem thema beschäftigt
sie auch nur das fleisch leisten also
hat der kann ja eigentlich nur noch
im grunde genommen nicht wenn ich sie
vegan leben eigentlich kann man auch
unterbrechen da da theoretisch selbst
ich finde auch klar der malische im
jetzt schon mit dem thema beschäftigt
dann am tier alles erfolgreich
radio sie sich also gerade ist für mich
absolviert wurde und in deutschland sind
nämlich geruch offen zu ich lebe nicht
es 7 millionen tiere die wir haben die
vegan ja aber dann mach doch mal so der
ehrlich gesagt zu viel moralische
überschuss
sterne millionen jungs können sich nur
züchter lena danach immer bitter als
in deutschland deutschland ist das
schülerin habe ich komme aus einem
zweitstärkste land nach frankreich
übrigens selbst wenn diese versuche alle
landkreis da ist sehr viel
massentierhaltung und ich habe als
die die noch rauchen und zwei jahre das
erfolgreich abgeschlossen wurden heißt
schülerin weil ich da da kann ich mehr
noch lange nicht dass sie am menschen
sind natürlich möchte ich die
verdienen als auf dem tennisplatz habe
durch gehen und eine der häufigsten
geschichten jahre ist schon auch die
ich bei einer hühnerzucht gearbeitet
versuche ist zum beispiel schwangere
frage warum es aber kaum haben wir diese
tiere zwangs zu füttern mit chemikalien
sogenannten unteren schichten sagen
allerdings nur zwei tage dann kann mich
lassen wo sie sind ja warum können die
substanzen aus mitte produkten und dann
ganz schnell auf den tennisplatz zurück
nur noch im lidl einkaufen warum haben
sehr reumütig dann musste man hühner
sie kein vernünftiges einkommen warum
guckt dann in der nacht tötet man das
ausstellen da leben drei hühner in einem
sind sie nicht mitgekommen bei der
tierchen mann scheint ihm den ball auf
lohnentwicklung warum haben wir die in
diesen tagen mal hipster veganen
und asyl alles und guckt wie diese
käfig der so groß wie ein din a4 blatt
substanzen auf das baby und auf die
irgendwas tritt nicht mitgenommen ja
dann muss man sie raus heben und dann
mutter gewürgt haben und das heißt aber
also das ist der soziale kosten und
bildet man so menschenketten man ahnt
noch lange nicht dass dieses produkt
insofern würde ich da das moralische
jemals an einer schwangeren frau
schon was am ende der menschenkette
statement auch nicht machen wollen aber
kommt ja aber diese tiere sind ja
zugelassen werden kann also im grunde
klar das muss eigentlich abgeräumt
vollgepumpt mit antibiotika die sind
genommen gibt es schon längst viel
werden also die tiere diese ganzen
günstigere methoden und viel humanere
total so aggressiv und dann ein mann
methoden aber sie kommen einfach sie
überhaupt keinen bock mehr auf treue
treten gar nicht in kraft diese